[موسيقى]
دمج الدعم السريع داخل الجيش السوداني ليس
هو كان لم يكن الشيء الوحيد
فكانت مشروع الدمج لسبعه جيوش في السودان
الدعم السريع القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وخمس حركات مسلحه وقعت على اتفاقيه جبل
السلام
[موسيقى]
هنا حصل اشتباكات كثيره من ناحيه عدم
التوافق السياسي من ناحيه عدم توفر
الموارد المطلوبه للدمج هذه الجيوش
وزياده على هذا الدعم السريع بنفسه
وقع على ورقه بالنسبه للمبادئ الاساسيه
لدمج الجيوش حيث حدد فيها اقصى حد هو عشر
سنين للدمج ووقعت وقعت كمان القوى
السياسيه والقوات المسلحه عليها ولكن
القوات المسلحه اصرت على دمج الدعم السريع
في خلال فتره زمنيه هي سنتين فهنا طبعا
حصلت الاشكاليه والزعزع
[موسيقى]
الدعم السريع اسس لنفسه منصه تجاريه
واقتصاديه واسعه جدا في السودان
فلديه موارد ذهب لديه تجاره
استيراد وتصدير موارد مختلفه فالدعم
السريع لديها الرياحيه في السودان لان يمد
او يقدم
موضوع الدمج
[موسيقى]